[Music]
we can't believe that you're returning
for the reboot of Gossip Girl Kristen
Bell just a fun thing to bring that show
back it was an easy yes you've come such
a long way from voicing the gossipy
bloggers but you're ready to pick up
where you left off we were stunned when
we found out who the real Gossip Girl
was and we definitely weren't the only
ones after hearing your voice for so
long
we were convinced that Gigi would look
and talk like you in real life but boy
were we wrong sorry if I'm being really
honest Rachel I don't think you can pull
off high school anymore
not only did Kristen Bell lend her voice
to Gossip Girl but she also made a cameo
in the final episode of the series but
Kristen wasn't the only celebrity to
star on the show because plenty of
big-time celebs briefly joined the cast
keep watching to find out which
riverdale actress portrayed in Upper
Eastside Dutchess for a total of four
episodes Lady gaga you guys talking
about Lady gaga no Blair I'm talking
about Gaga Ahmadinejad First Lady of
Iran Lady Gaga is one of the biggest
stars in the world and back in 2009 she
performed her musical number bad romance
for the Upper East Siders they used to
play cards together who do you think
okra faces about the episode titled the
last days of disco stick starred not one
but two big-time celebs bad romance was
one of the biggest hits of 2009 so
Gossip Girl fans totally lost it when
Lady Gaga made a cameo appearance on the
show
Krysten Ritter in 2009 Krysten Ritter
made waves when she played Jane
margulies on Breaking Bad but that same
year Kristen also scored on a small role
on Gossip Girl in which she portrayed a
young Carol Rhodes in the episode titled
Valley Girls as it turned out both
Krysten Ritter and Kristen Bell start
together on Veronica Mars before joining
the cast of Gossip Girl it's not forever
not once we get Shep's music video on
MTV I'm turtling Starr Hilary Duff
Hilary Duff has accomplished a lot since
leaving the set of Lizzie McGuire but
most of her notable roles was the one of
Olivia Burke on Gossip Girl I grew up on
these
as cruelest like my family in 2009
Hillary appeared in a total of six
episodes both Hillary and Lady gaga
appeared in the episode titled the last
days of disco stick
we loved Hillary's scandalous gossip
girl's storyline Melissa Fumero Melissa
Fumero plays the adorkable Amy Santiago
on Brooklyn nine-nine it's hard to
imagine her acting any other way I
haven't gotten an F since I failed
recess in second grade teachers need a
break chew Amy
we were totally stunned when we realized
that Melissa starred as Zoey aka
girl number one on Gossip Girl for a
total of three years
Melissa's character acted as one of
Blair Waldorf's ladies-in-waiting it's
hard to believe that Amy and Zoey are
played by the same actress where's here
you're in trouble
Britney's snow just like Krysten Ritter
Brittany snow appeared in a single
episode of Gossip Girl in 2009 both
Kristen and Brittany's characters
starred in flashback scenes in which
Brittany portrayed a young Lily van der
Woodsen is this memory fall in love with
me since then Brittany has gone on to
star in movies like pitch perfect one
two and three and the late bloomer
machen a Mick you may know her as Alice
Cooper from Riverdale or sherry
tinsdale's
Gilmore Girls but to the Upper East Side
she's known as Duchess Catherine Beaton
I wasn't expecting anyone so young
madchen Amick guest-starred in four
episodes of Gossip Girl in 2008 her role
on the show surely spice things up she
was the slightly older woman who got all
caught up with Nate Archibald Tyra Banks
Tyra Banks rules the runway as the
long-standing host an executive producer
of America's Next Top Model and that's
never stopped her from landing acting
gigs on the side in 2009 Tyra appeared
as Ursula Nyquist on Gossip Girl in the
episode titled Dan de florette Tyra and
Hilary Duff's characters both played
actresses on the show Ivana Trump you
know you're a big deal when you guest
star as yourself on a popular TV series
like Gossip Girl Ivanka Trump is a
successful businesswoman and
entrepreneur having her own jewelry and
fashion lines amongst many other
accomplishments in 2010 Ivanka briefly
appeared in the episode titled ezj
Rachel Bilson just like I've Vanka
Rachel Bilson guest-starred as herself
in the episode titled New York I love
you xoxo this was back in 2010 around
the time Rachel was cast us 2d on How I
Met Your Mother Rachael and Kristen Bell
joined forces to help reveal Gossip
Girls true identity wait Sebastian Stan
Sebastian Stan isn't someone who is easy
to forget but after all the success he
had after starring on Gossip Girl
it can be hard to remember that he
portrayed Carter Bazin Serena's
boyfriend on the show
all habits die hard today sebastian is
known for playing a Marvel superhero
Bucky Barnes aka the Winter Soldier here
at the things we post fun videos about
your favorite TV shows movies and actors
every single day if you are excited
about the Gossip Girl reboot hit that
big red subscribe button to stay in the
loop and don't forget to click that bell
to get notified whenever we post a new
video if you're tuning in on your mobile
go on YouTube settings and turn on
notifications and that's a wrap on the
10 celebs you totally forgot we're on
Gossip Girl who is your favorite Gigi
character and who are you most excited
to see in the reboot sound off in the
comments thanks for watching the things
and don't forget to give this video a
big thumbs up we'll see you next time